E aí
Oi boa tarde a todos eu quando recebi o
convite duas semanas atrás para
participar do tédio fiquei muito
contente e logo em seguida a notícia Não
é para falar de saneamento e o seu tema
é como fazer acontecer O saneamento no
estado do Rio de Janeiro eu dei para
trás e pensei duas vezes porque
realmente é um Desafio extremamente
complicado que até hoje não foi vencido
mas quando eu li o bloco aonde eu fui
encaixado do desafio a gente Verifica
que o espírito é ousar e Inovar e eu vou
contar para vocês aqui duas experiências
da minha vida profissional que eu passei
e que eu acho que dá para contribuir
numa discussão de como a gente dá esse
passo para universalizar o saneamento
aqui na região metropolitana e no nosso
estado em uma dessas experiências foi na
região dos lagos
em
1999/2000 aqueles que conhecem a região
viram a Lagoa de Araruama mudar
completamente de cor né aquela Lagoa
antes Cristalina passou a ficar
eutrofizada que que é esse negócio
eutrofizada quando você
joga o esgoto no corpo hídrico esse
esgoto é no primeiro momento alimento
para os seres que ali vivem peixes e
microrganismos a partir de um certo
momento de um excesso esse alimento vira
adubo não é para as algas e fim para
fitoplânctons que são algas
pequenininhos a água muda de cor e você
tem uma explosão de algas e foi o que
aconteceu com aquela região em 2 mil até
2004 quem presenciou ou ouviu cenas
realmente terríveis na a gente bom dia
imagens que eram cotidianas nesse
período de 2000/2004 centenas de
funcionários retirando algas de dentro
daquela Lagoa todo dia e os prefeitos
dizendo eu não tenho mais como fazer
isso é enxugar gelo né obviamente a
lagoa de por o durante 30 anos desde a
ponte rio-niterói um crescimento naquela
região sem qualquer saneamento ela deu
conta até onde Ela aguentou e a partir
dali não aguentou mais então o cenário
que a gente tinha nessa região era um
cenário a de um contrato recém-feito de
concessão para o serviço de saneamento
onde a água era prioridade porque
naquela época o problema da região dos
lagos ela falta da água carro-pipa e
esqueceram de perceber que é o aumentar
de 600 dias para 1.800 litros por
segundo a água e equacionar melhorar bem
a situação de água você também triplicou
o volume de esgoto que ia prestar Lagoa
e o e
inevitavelmente iria acontecer nessa
ocasião cinco mil carros-pipa de esgoto
e um para Lagoa por dia Se alguém
conseguir imaginar essa cena enfim ele
era cinco mil carros-pipa e abre para
ver o que que era despejado diariamente
e essa região ainda tinha um outro
agravante a sazonalidade uma região que
tem não chega a 300 mil habitantes mas
que no verão só Cabo Frio ultrapassa 1
milhão de habitantes como é que você vai
ter saneamento para essa quantidade de
pessoas no período como esse e
obviamente poucos recursos para dar
conta desse recado a solução que essa
região encontrou ancorada na nossa lei
de recurso hídrico que já prever a
necessidade de sentar sociedade governo
e
empresas né e usuários para discutir os
seus problemas mas é uma coisa que
realmente não é fácil de fazer essa
região conseguiu fazer essa discussão Eu
atribuo muitas é a
máxima de que a desgraça une realmente
une nesse caso aqui o desespero era tal
que todo mundo queria ser agarrar em
alguma coisa para tentar sair dessa
situação e começaram a partir do ano
2000 uma série de oficinas e discussões
na algumas bastante tensas né não é
fácil botar governo e sociedade civil e
empresa junto governo não está
acostumado a partilhar poder não gosta
de ter que dividir a discussão da a
sociedade civil também não está
acostumada a sentar e ouvir o outro lado
Normalmente quando ela entra numa arena
dessa ela já botou o dedo em riste já
acusa é uma situação
difícil né e as empresas elas ficam um
pouco no meio do caminho não quer nem
desagradar o governo e nem desagradar a
sociedade para não ficar reclamando
então elas vão tá tirando esperando ver
o que que vai acontecer
E aí função disso tudo se Conseguiu dar
os primeiros passos no sentido de
discutir uma solução para essa região e
diante dos parcos recursos que se tinham
o que que se propôs fazendo essa região
usando conhecimento técnico uma região
que chove pouco né bem abaixo da Média
normal uma região onde já sabia que o eu
tiro esse alimento da lagoa de uma vez
tira o grande quantidade desses gol da
Lagoa ou ela vai continuar eu trouxe
usada né vai continuar com aquela
coloração que a gente vê bem em
Jacarepaguá aquela cor verde é
exatamente processo de eutrofização
então é a discussão foi num sistema que
não é o tradicional da engenharia
sanitária engenharia sanitária clássica
propõe que a gente ponha as redes na
porta de cada casa e tudo um sistema
desse para essa região
custaria uma fortuna e levaria um tempo
imenso o papel lá qual seria a situação
da Lagoa Então se discutiu a realização
de um cinturão que a sociedade civil
apelido de esgoto via nome bastante
óbvio para isso interceptando teve um
projeto nessa época que identificou
380 galeria jogando esgoto na lagoa
apresentam começou a se cercar
interceptar mais fazer isso não foi
fácil porque as concessionárias tinha lá
o seu contrato não queriam mexer muito
com essa questão e a sociedade civil a
própria engenharia por não aceitar não
era muito fácil propor fazer esse
sistema né como é que você vai gerenciar
uma coisa que não tá dentro da
engenharia clássica mas houve muita
briga a gente tem uma uma foto aqui que
mostra bem na uma das dezenas de
audiências na agência reguladora onde
vim aí a sociedade com pescadores e
massa questionar a a mudança do contrato
e a cidade Há muitos outros
desdobramentos dessa luta o fato aqui a
região conseguiu mudar Esses contratos
EA partir do ano de 2004 né ela chegou
numa velocidade muito grande a sessenta
por cento de tratamento e a lagoa
começou a responder muito rápido né
depois de sete anos já tinha oitenta por
cento de tratamento isso não significa
que se abandonou a rede separativa ela
vem aumentando nos grandes centros para
ensinar grande senso nas cidades mesmo
nas áreas mais densas mas paulatinamente
de acordo com a capacidade de
investimento mas é um é um feito
interessante em que o poder da sociedade
local permitiu fazer uma solução
diferente hoje é reconhecido esse
trabalho você vê aí tem uma foto
comemorando
os pescadores feliz da vida com
perumbeba baixo 14 16 kg que já não eram
vistas na lagoa mais de 101 a bastante
difíceis em contrato o que que fez a
diferença nesse sistema né fez diferença
sistema escolhida a discussão feita
participação social o controle social
sobre as empresas porque o capitalismo
ele é selvagem Leão se você não exercer
o controle social certamente as metas
não vão chegar e lá isso é discutido
muito transparente do quanto entra
Quanto sai a ponto de que a sociedade
ao discutir depois de sistema ficar
pronto a forma de pagar né dentro dessas
funções concordou com o aumento da
tarifa de água para suportar o sistema
de tratamento a operação dele que não
havia como fazer isso de outra forma e
nem vai se cobrar uma tarifa de esgoto
se o sistema tradicional não está
implantado uma tarifa cheia de esgoto
então é uma solução a interessante eu
queria trazer e a outra de respeito aos
lixões do Estado do Rio de Janeiro nem
todo mundo e sabe o acompanha a mídia
falou muito agora sobre a questão da
política nacional de resíduos sólidos
lições que não Acabaram o estado do Rio
adotou uma política que eu acho
interessante da eu quis trazer essa
exemplo para cá porque
ele ele tem algumas características
diferentes também do padrão né uma delas
foi dá corda para iniciativa privada né
que eu obviamente como capital ela tem
interesse aonde é possível aferir algum
retorno E aí a houve um investimento
perto das áreas mais densas aonde você
tem maior quantidade de resíduos em
sentar gem de tratamento de esgoto tão
mapa aqui não tá ajudando na cor mas
essas áreas Azul Claras foram se
configurando
áreas Aonde a iniciativa privada
demonstrou interesse e foi aglutinando a
com o apoio do Estado municípios Em
volta dela e essa mais clara aqui se
Amarelo são municípios que deram conta
do seu recado né estavam fazendo seu
trabalho e foi respeitado direitinho
trabalho dele e sobraram áreas mais
pobres não é mais periféricas municípios
menores onde o estado entrou dando um
apoio mas o Curioso dessa estratégia é
que diferente de tudo que tinha sido
pensado até hoje que é fácil desenhar
numa prancheta como é que eu faço os
arranjos ir e levo isso aqui foi a
geopolítica se moldando a discussão
Prefeito com prefeito e formando a esse
desenho até cobrir o estado inteiro
Então esse é um é uma coisa também
diferente interessante que aconteceu e
aqui isso não é quadro político mas é
tem uma margem de erro aí para mais três
ou para menos três mas o estado do Rio
de um avanço muito grande ele conseguiu
passar de 10 porcento de lixo as
centrais resido para mais de noventa
porcento indo e tem chance de ser um dos
poucos Estados da Federação a zerar
claro que nós somos 90 municípios muito
mais simples do que o outro mas alguns
instrumentos importantes que fizeram a
diferença aí é são ferramentas muito
inteligentes e como ICMS Ecológico o
município pequeno de 20 toneladas dia
que é aquele que tem dificuldade quando
ele se junta com os outros se consegue
fazer o que ele recebe disso MS
Ecológico a partir do ano seguinte paga
a despesa dele que eles então não é como
o prefeito não teria entrar no negócio
desse então é alguns outros itens aqui
que fizeram diferença estratégia de
público-privado trazer a usar o privado
sim a nosso favor foram a fundamentais
para garantir
uma condição de trabalho é claro
tivermos fazer uma lei para garantir que
o Privado não possa desistir no meio do
caminho não quero mais brincar e fecha
lá o Aterro e o a central de resido e
amanhã deixa um monte de municípios a
mão então uma lei foi feita para
garantir que isso não aconteça que haja
uma regulação dessa atividade para e
passa uma futuro o que que eu trouxe
esses dois exemplos para dizer Esse
desafio de fazer acontecer O saneamento
no estado do Rio de Janeiro eu quis
trazer duas experiências para gente
avaliar Esse é o panorama do Estado hoje
a gente vê em cor clara né próximo do
zero cor escura acima dos oitenta por
cento então a gente vê o quadro difícil
da implementação quadro ainda precária
da implementação do saneamento no estado
e a gente via nesse outro quadro aqui
não o que pode ser chamado de desarranjo
operacional o estado do rio tem uma
quantidade de arranjos ora é público na
água não tem ninguém Lisboa Thor é um
serviço municipal na água não tem
ninguém de fora tem um Municipal Naruto
a e no fundo esgoto na casa que não tem
ninguém é a situação é essa que a gente
vê precária a gente vê algum avanço
maior naqueles que têm ao contrato
concedido porque a uma uma pressão mais
forte da sociedade como esse caso da
região dos lagos que a gente mostrou e
agora uns planos de saneamento que a lei
de saneamento preconizou que tem que
ficar pronto agora mostram que nós vamos
precisar seguramente mais de 20 milhões
né para fazer um sistema de saneamento
só a região dos lagos são três bilhões
para você botar rede naquela região
então atingir a 100 porcento Então esse
é o universo que no ritmo que a gente tá
andando dentro do Estado nós vamos levar
seguramente mais de 30 anos para ter a
rede terá rede não significa que você
vai conseguir despoluir porque muita
gente não se liga você tem Fontes
difusas que não são controladas desde o
posto de gasolina
é aquela caixa de gordura que ninguém
cuida e que numa Metrópole isso começa a
avolumar e se você não tiver algumas
alternativas de você vai ter seriamente
dificuldade mesmo implantando o sistema
Total então a dados do trata Brasil do
próprio
plansab Nacional você
verifica que o Rio de Janeiro tem mais
de sessenta por cento de
afastamento de esgoto não é a rede de
coleta é que é muito comum as
prefeituras
arrumar em uma rua colocarem as manilhas
pluviais e todo mundo Se liga nas
manilhas E afasta o esgoto das suas
casas mas ele chega cada vez mais
rápidos nos rios e da Baía de Guanabara
nas Lagoas e a gente vai tendo uma
situação mais caótica então hoje o nosso
indice de tratamento que tá em torno de
trinta por cento né Poderia voluir bem
mais rápido um simples ensaio seguindo
essa lógica de consorciamento eu disse
buscar parceria
público-privada né e de investimentos de
Médio prazo do Estado mostram que a
gente poderia sim chegar a níveis de
tratamento muito rápido dos sessenta por
cento que já correm aí pelas Galerias
subterrâneas e no Médio prazo aí chegar
oitenta por cento com investimentos
dessa ordem que estão aqui é isso É
claro é um ensaio é aqui para provocar é
para gente discutir mas mostra aqui esse
recurso que o estado teria que entrar
que estão em verde aqui ele tem hoje no
seu fundo de recurso hídrico Ele tem no
seu fundo de conservação ambiental com
os olhos de petróleo e tem na
contrapartida que as prefeituras
poderiam dar com o ICMS Ecológico então
poderia ser alcançado esse estágio Não
curto espaço de tempo como aconteceu na
região dos lagos para gente poder na
sequência evoluir e colocar
o
separativas em toda a região tão
essa discussão do tempo seco ela tem que
se dar num fórum como os comitês de
bacia com a participação da sociedade
com a discussão se aqui é viável aqui
não é o como que é e eu não tô falando
de tratar Rio como Pierre bem colocou de
manhã que eles cantam absurdo a gente
pegar um rio e ter que tratar ele eu tô
falando a gente te sinto longe ao longo
dos rios no primeiro momento coletando
Copacabana tem-se Copacabana não tivesse
uma galeria de tempo seco que a gente tá
vendo aí na foto você teria hoje com
todo o sistema de saneamento desde a
década de 60 você teria vazamento em
todas as Galerias em cada esquina de
praia então a diferença é que se você
faz isso e caminha para o separativo ou
se você só faz o separativo né com um
prazo de tempo muito maior para chegar
nessa solução agora isso depende da
participação da sociedade nos fóruns O
que é um comitê de bacia ou instâncias
locais onde você possa discutir esse
assunto e levar essa proposta
junto com o governo para ser
implementada então a gente tem o Casos
hoje com índices alto e todos eles
utilizam essa metodologia ao caso em
Niterói Petrópolis também tá fazendo
para poder ter os rios poluídos num
primeiro momento até que você avança
então A ideia é ar aqui trazer para
vocês com base em duas experiências que
nós temos um caminho né que é possível e
a pergunta é se nós estamos prontos para
participar da desses dessa discussão e
levar ela a Fundo junto com os
governantes para frente obrigado a
E aí